this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nothing because at the
end of the day that's what most of us
need yeah I mean come on guys what do
you think were going to do try to sell
mattresses or sweat wicking underwear to
you
advertisements suck so enjoy the show
100% advertisement free every little
thing you think that's mean every little
thing you think that you need every
little thing that's just feeding your
greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without me
hey everybody this is Joshua fields
Millburn and this is Ryan Nicodemus and
that makes us the minimalists welcome to
episode 2 of the minimalists podcast
first off before we get started I'd love
to thank you all of you for making our
very first episode climb to the the top
of the iTunes charts that was really
unexpected we really hoped that this
thing would do well but thanks to you we
hit the top 40 of all podcasts we hit
number 2 in our category and the number
one podcast episode in our category as
well which just was amazing so thank you
so much for that thank you for all the
reviews on iTunes that we read every
single one of them and thank you for
making this journey and awesome one for
us let's go ahead and get started with
our minimal monologue of today my rant
this week is about irony now when you
call yourselves the minimalists man
everything you do is instantly ironic
you know and people love love to give
you a hard time when you call yourself a
minimalist let alone the minimalist you
know though they find it necessary to
point out every irony every incongruity
every gotcha moment yeah you notice when
I was writing this morning and I was
writing about an experience I had in the
corporate
roll with my boss and how I was
explaining to him what the minimalists
were when he first discovered it and as
I was writing I remember like oh yeah
the very first thing he pointed out to
me was how I wasn't a minimalist because
I snowboarded because I had all that
snowboarding equipment that went with it
and that was that was within just like
the first few months of the website and
then of course yeah everywhere we go
they're like hey you guys don't really
draw on a minimal crowd do you certainly
don't certainly don't sell a minimal
amount of books your hair Josh it's not
very minimal right and so everything you
do ends up being steeped in irony and
really I find that people throw all
these little cavils at us because they
trying to justify their own lifestyle by
in a way point out how we are living as
minimalist is wrong and you know what
for some people it may be wrong for them
it may not be appropriate for their
lives and that's okay we're not out
trying to convert anyone to our
lifestyle we want to share this recipe
with you and if sometimes that makes
something ironic then so be it
but ultimately when dealing with
criticism I learned that that our
judgments are but a mere that reflect
the insecurities of the person who's
doing the judging and so ultimately when
we criticize something when we gossip
about someone we're just showing our own
insecurities about about that topic so
yes sometimes minimalism can be ironic
but we're not trying to live like monks
we're not trying to live with nothing
we're trying to live what's appropriate
for our lives yeah it's funny on
periscope the other day we had that guy
comment where he was like these guys
didn't get rid of anything important why
are they minimalist and Josh you had the
best to come back to that Reid
yeah you're right we didn't get rid of
anything important we got rid of that
which was superfluous we got the excess
out of the way so we could actually
figure out what was important in our
lives and through that process of
elimination we found out what the
important things are we found out that
health is important relationships are
or in creativity and passion and growth
in contribution and all of these things
are really important but most of those
things aren't things at all let's let's
move on to our our voicemail a question
of of the day in fact we have three
voicemails today all about sort of
technology and social media and
everything in that realm we'll start
with a voicemail from Jeff hey guys
I saw your podcast one really enjoyed it
and I did have one question because
seems to me that in my life right now
and try to minimize things that a lot is
going on with too much information
coming in from different sources all the
times to emails and Twitter and snapchat
and email and it's just I know you guys
even have so many different sites and I
feel like I'm missing out on things if I
don't keep up with everything I think
he's just cluttering my life and just
want to know if you guys have a way of
kind of dealing with that and addressing
I guess information overload it's in
social media and everything else that we
want to be involved in and interested in
but it just seems like if we're not into
and everything we're missing out on
things it just kind of gets overwhelming
so hope that make sense and are keep up
the good work
appreciate everything you do and there
it's really making our difference in my
life and here's a voicemail from Emily
hi Josh and Ryan my name is Emily and
I'm calling from New Orleans I'd like
you all to share your thoughts on
browsing online shopping sites or phone
applications regularly and tending not
to purchase anything but instead just
doing this simply to view fashion as
well as strategies to kick this habit
all right thanks Emily and here's one
more message from Richard hey guys my
name is Richard from south jersey the
better half in New Jersey right in
Cherry Hill area and I really enjoy the
spod cast I mean I was waiting at the
doctor's office and you know spending
now up to an hour waiting and I just
couldn't think of a better time to spend
it than to listen to how to make my life
more valuable or
no more minimalistic and now the
question I have is nowadays everyone has
a lot of Technology you know cell phones
and tablets laptops everything like that
how did how can you extend the this
minimalistic lifestyle into your tech
world I just hope that you can speak on
that a bit
really enjoy your podcast and hope you
get back to me so basically it seems
like what these three callers are asking
is the same thing in a different way
it's how do minimalist handle social
media and Technology and also sort of
alluding toward the the fear of missing
out yeah I guess you know just to start
with what the Jeff's he specifically
brings up Twitter and snapchat and all
those crazy social media outlets that we
have where we have this awesome bit of
communication to use and certainly it
can be a great tool to use but yeah it
can certainly be overwhelming yeah I
mean basically I think our tools are
only as good or as bad as the person
using them use this analogy before but a
chainsaw can cut down a rotting backyard
tree preventing it from impaling your
neighbor's home or that same chains'll
can be used to hurt that same neighbor
to chop them into tiny little pieces or
or a can of paint can be used to
beautify your home's facade or you might
use it to graffiti the walls and an
otherwise pristine public park and I
think the same goes for technology it's
just a tool you know we can use Twitter
and Facebook and Google+ and Pinterest
and all these other places to enrich our
lives and enrich the lives of others to
communicate express ourselves and share
things that we couldn't otherwise share
as easily or we can get stuck in that
social media Bermuda Triangle right we
can Corrine from Facebook to Instagram
to youtube and just stay stuck and the
meaningless glow of our screens and may
I use my phone all the time to to
photograph gorgeous landscapes message
loved ones map out directions etc but
that's really about the intention we
have and how we plan to to use the
devices and I think the bottom line is
that it's up to us to determine how
we're going to use our chain souls and
our paint cans and our technology
ultimately our tools are just tools and
it's our responsibility to ask important
questions about how and why we use those
tools but of course you don't have to
use all of them and so some of these
people are looking for sort of tips like
how do I identify all of these things
I'm overwhelmed with now Ryan and I
typically don't talk about depriving
yourself of something we don't think
minimalism minimalism is about
deprivation but you know sometimes it's
ok to temporarily deprive yourself so
you can figure out what truly adds value
to your life and I've gone through some
experiments and in my life I got rid of
home internet maybe four years ago and I
wrote an essay about this the
minimalists calm slash internet about my
experience of getting rid of the
internet for one month and I'll tell you
what it was the most productive month of
my life and I ended up never getting
that that internet back and I got rid of
my TV and realized that I was more
productive without that but I've also
done other sort of stoical experiments
deprived myself temporarily of say my
cell phone but after two months without
that I realized that yeah I was using
that cell phone not very deliberately
went but I could bring it back into my
life because there were some things that
really added value to my life
and so I was addicted to the smartphone
and we get we can get
addicted to technology and sometimes
it's okay to disconnect so that we can
move on yeah I think the key takeaway
here for Jeff is to ask yourself that
question with each platform that is
stressing you out the ones that you
brought up on the voicemail you know is
snapchat is a really adding value or is
it more of an ephemeral ephemeral way of
pacifying yourself that's something that
I would ask with each application in
fact that's what Josh and I do I mean we
have Google+ we have Pinterest we have
Twitter and Facebook we have a lot of
help managing that I shouldn't say a lot
we add a little bit of help managing
those accounts just does an awesome job
with that but we did pick those
platforms very specifically we don't
have a tumblr page that we keep up with
we don't have one app chat app chat what
are the it yeah the kids do in these
days yeah so there's a lot of stuff that
we avoided specifically because we felt
like these platforms we had it reached
the broadest audience and we felt like
we could not only get the most value of
it but add the most value with it as
well you know for both of us I think
Ryan's favorite social media platform
I'm not sure what it is exactly mine's
Twitter and I get a lot of value from
that if I were to use just one social
media platform that would be it for me
it's because of the just the nature of
it the short communication I use it to
curate my news and my entertainment and
and I found that just using one primary
social media feed is a really great way
so temporarily deprive yourself maybe
get rid of all social media for a month
do what some people call a a digital
sabbatical and if you do that digital
sabbatical you'll really realize which
one you're gravitating toward toward
more as well yeah and just maybe stop
using one at a time if it's three
different social media outlets that are
driving your life crazy then just get
rid of one of them and see how less
crazy your life isn't I feel and I would
say the reason that we use so many for
the minimalist isn't because we find a
ton of value in a bunch of different
platforms we actually don't but we
realized that just because I find
you in Twitter that doesn't mean that
everyone else will and so we use these
as communication platforms as well it's
very likely that if we weren't trying to
communicate with a large group of people
we would each just pick our one favorite
platform and and have that it's okay to
just have one and we talked about the
the fear of missing out or alluded to
that in the voicemail and I'll tell you
what we're always going to be missing
out on something no matter what you do
no matter how much information you
consume there is an infinite amount of
information out there and you're going
to miss out on roughly a hundred percent
of that information no matter how much
of your time is spent on Instagram and
Twitter and everywhere else and no
matter how often you're reaching into
your pocket and and incessantly checking
the email on the smartphone and and text
messages and Facebook posts etc you're
still missing out on everything else
that's out there yeah Leo pabout he's
got a essay that he wrote a while back
you can find it at Zen habits dotnet
forward slash thirty ninth it was in
regards to his 39th birthday but there's
a great paragraph in here that says the
truth is we could run around trying to
do everything exciting and travel around
the world and always stay in touch with
our iPhone and crack berries and work
and party all day long without sleep but
we could never do it all we will always
be missing something and right now as
Josh and I are recording this podcast
we're missing out a 99.9% of the other
things going on in the world but we've
very deliberately chosen to do this
podcast and to add as much value as we
can and yes we're ignoring everything
else right now and missing out on
everything else because the truth is is
where you will always be missing out and
so ultimately pick what is going to add
the most value to your life and
sometimes the way to figure that out is
by temporarily depriving yourself I'll
end with this in terms of my temporary
deprivation I wrote an essay last year
called most emergencies aren't and I'm
going to read a few problems I had
and a few solutions I had to the
technology that was creating the problem
in my life in the first place
this is most emergencies aren't a few
years ago after chucking my television
and jettison my home Internet I locked
my cell phone in a drawer for a few
months
boy oh boy did I learn a lot about my
lonely distracted self after removing
those pacifiers from my reach
and then here's a list of what I called
smart phone problems number one
addiction I was addicted to my smart
phone constantly twitching for the next
quote important email viral video or
Facebook message ignoring the world in
front of me
for a universe of zeros and ones number
two disconnection our technology is
wonderful it has enabled us to connect
with the infinite expanse of the world
but it has also given us a weapon to
sever our deepest connections true we
can tweet with folks from other
continents in fact I've met most of my
closest friends online but in doing so
we sometimes isolate ourselves from the
person sitting across from us number
three dependency like a child security
blanket I needed my phone to feel safe
calm whole and just like that child when
I lost it man I lost it
panic struck each time my hand and
voluntarily breached the pocket where
the device normally waited for me number
four impulsivity the opposite of
intention is impulse which accurately
described my former relationship with my
smartphone I acted primarily on impulse
always reacting to what my phone
instructed me to do I wasn't using the
phone the phone was using me number five
this is the last problem that I had with
the smartphone urgency my cell phone
came equipped
with a false sense of urgency which
helped me construct a facade of spurious
self-importance of course I needed my
phone on me at all times because I'm so
damn important that you know what if
someone needs to get a hold of me right
now in reality that's nearly never the
case because most emergencies aren't
real emergencies truth be told I'm an
outstanding friend but if you have a
real emergency I'm not the best guy to
call if your water heater breaks call a
plumber if a burglar strikes call the
police if someone gets injured call
9-1-1 once the professionals have
quashed the crisis leave me a voicemail
I'll be there soon to help pick up the
pieces and here are some solutions I
came up with when I eventually
reintroduced the cell phone into my life
my everyday life I realized that the
phone was never the problem I was the
problem so I developed to work a
framework to help solve that problem
today while I'm certainly not perfect I
do my best to use my smart phone
intentionally first this is a
distractions email and Facebook no
longer reside on my device nor does
anything else I proceed perceived as a
waste of time and apps I haven't used in
the last month
are deleted to number two interruptions
notifications both visual and auditory
do not exist on my phone no banners
sounds or alerts of any kind I don't
need to be quote notified which really
means interrupted every time someone
double taps a photo on Instagram
number three barriers in the presence of
friends I leave the phone in the car or
at home because I've realized when we
place our phones on the table in front
of us we actually send a subtle message
to our loved ones your only important
until something or someone more
important interrupts us
removing the phone however removes an
invisible barrier from our interactions
and shows the people we care about that
we do in fact care about them number
four tethers at home my phone has its
own home docked on a charging stand I
use it only at that location when I'm
home
allowing me to otherwise untether from
the device which helps me tether myself
to more important tasks writing/reading
sleeping number five tools the phone is
a valuable tool but only if it adds
value to our lives
nowaday I use the phone for texts phone
calls music podcasts audiobooks GPS and
anything that truly serves a purpose
uber hotel in-flight apps a notepad a
dictionary app and the glorious Kindle
app which is now located in the spot
formerly occupied by my Facebook app
that's really great hack by the way if
you're incessantly checking one app
replace it with one that's much more
meaningful like the Kindle app I find
myself reading a lot more when I used to
just check Instagram or Twitter yeah
that was a great tip you gave me that I
use now it's like every time I go to
twitch to go on social media I'm like
maybe I should just pull up and read a
couple pages of that book yeah yeah
definitely adds more value and the last
solution I came up with was something
called Nevers and of course as a
reformed man there are a few things I'll
never do with my phone now I'll never
text and drive again I'll never reach
for my phone while standing at a urinal
again and I'll never use my phone in bed
again because the bed is meant for two
things neither of which involve call
logs or text messages we are all
fighting our own battles with technology
look up from your device and you'll see
a sea of lonely people lost in the
tantalizing glow of their screens
trading and tension for impulse our
wonderful gadgets have given us access
to overwhelming
convenience but if we squander that
convenience we'll find ourselves crushed
by the weight of our impulses searching
pixels for meaning when there are
countless reasons to live on this side
of the screen
yes technology has undoubtedly made our
lives better so much so that we wouldn't
want to live without it
so we must find a way to live with it
preach you know there's a whole chapter
on technology in our book essential
which is an essay collection that we put
out in 2015 it was actually a we did
three or three different books there
were a bunch of different essay
collections and we unpublished all of
them and they're no longer available
because we wanted to put all into one
book and really have a lot of value in
one tome for everyone so Jeff Emily
Richard we're gonna send you a copy an
autographed copy of essential essays by
the minimalist oh that reminds me Emily
and Richard that's right
if they had voicemails to know it's
funny I didn't want to address Emily's
voice my I thought it was really funny
how she talked about you know what about
those shopping apps especially if you
want to just go on and look at the
shopping app not intending to buy
anything what are your thoughts on that
and I I'm not gonna lie I kind of
chuckled when I heard that because I
would have say of course not you don't
need shopping apps on your phone that's
uh that's crazy but but yeah if you're
going to tempt yourself by using
shopping apps all I can say is using
shopping apps to keep up with fashion
all I can say is you're probably setting
yourself up for for bringing unnecessary
things into your life there's no doubt
about it
yeah we are what we desire and if we
constantly sold this meme of success and
beauty through a shopping app or
Pinterest or Etsy or something like that
those apps aren't inherently bad we use
Pinterest to post beautiful art and
architecture which I look at as art but
if we are if it's an impulse for us to
to look at those throughout the day and
desire those things then maybe we're not
desiring what will actually enhance our
life yeah and Richard talked a little
bit about equipment and that made me
think about upgrades how we are all
tempted to upgrade it's like I know I
was especially one that that iPhone six
came out I was like wow look at that
thing it's it's got I don't know what
does it have on there Gorilla Glass and
a couple other cool features got a
bigger screen and when I really looked
at it you know the iPhone six didn't do
anything more for me that my current
phone did and I'm sure there's some
listeners out there who would argue
differently and say oh there's so many
things you can do with the iPhone 6
here's why you need it and I would say
that's awesome that you find that tool
valuable in your life but I didn't but
those are the kind of questions I ask
myself before I upgrade any of my
technology yeah you have to be honest
with yourself and remove it temporarily
see how that affects your life and then
bring things back into your life more
deliberately and constantly ask that
question does this add value to my life
and and if it doesn't you have to be
willing to let go so hope you enjoy
those books guys hope these answer your
questions and if you do enjoy the books
minimize them afterward hand it off to
someone else who can find value in it
there's no need to hold on to it
obviously once you've gotten value from
it because the values in the word is not
in the the physical artifact itself you
ready to move on to the lightning round
yeah so this is a third segment of our
podcast is the hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round this is
folks on social media they ask us a
bunch a bunch of questions about you
know whatever they want but it's
lightning round questions with long
Laundering answers usually so if you if
you have a question for us or a comment
about how you
to handle social media or technology
before we move on to that just give us a
call we'll have our phone number at the
end of this podcast we'd love to hear
some of your tips on how you can improve
social media and if you have tips for
Jeff Emily or Richard we'd love to get
your tips for our comment section at the
end of the podcast as well so yes we
have a bunch of questions from Twitter
at the minimalists yeah Twitter Ryan so
here's some questions from some folks
who have used the hashtag ask the
minimalists Abigail
I'm sorry Abigail Nelson writes how do
you approach minimalism when your spouse
has no interest in owning less minimize
the spouse next question I'm just
kidding we're just kidding don't
minimize your spouse that's silly you
know with my girlfriend at home her and
I have a very good understanding of each
other and we've worked on that ever
since we started dating we've been
together for over two years now so first
I chose my significant other very very
carefully and made sure that we had the
same values and beliefs which I'm sure
everyone else has done but sometimes we
we may change a value here or there and
that's okay
because the partner that were with if
they truly love us if they truly
appreciate us if they truly respect us
they would at least support us in our
endeavors and that's how Mariah and I
are you know she's got I think on the
Today Show I said she had 20 pairs of
shoes she actually has about 30 or 35
pairs of shoes she counts them each way
he does a full inventory she made sure
what he wish he can keep or Kent that's
right no that's that is not how it works
no she actually corrected me after she's
like I got way more shoes than that you
know Abigail
here's what I'll say and I'd love to
send you a copy of minimalism live a
meaningful life it was our very first
book but there's we just published a
second edition of that book and really
enhance some of the chapters there but
one of the chapters one of the five
values in our
lives that Ryan and I have has to do
with relationships and so I think that
will help but ultimately you have to
understand the point of this all the
purpose of minimalism isn't about just
owning less and so you say that your
spouse has no interest in owning less
while owning less isn't the point I
don't have any interest in just owning
less well my interests are in doing
something more meaningful with my life
and that's the point and so helping your
significant other identified the
benefits of getting the excess stuff out
of the way might help him or her to
actually clear some of the clutter now
their perspective may not be the same as
yours they might have a different
personality or different desires but as
long as you have similar values I think
you can get to the same place even
though you have a different route of
getting there
now if you do have radically different
values in life well then you're probably
headed in different directions and you
have to ask some more difficult
questions about about that relationship
then you want to move on the next
question yeah spooky Ren says any advice
for artists who are struggling finding
balance with supplies materials and
staying minimalist I actually been asked
this question before I think more
broadly let's look at someone who has a
collection maybe it's a library
maybe maybe you've got a huge library
full of books whatever it may be it's
funny people come up to us all the time
look I'm not as minimalist as you
because I have a lot of art supplies or
because I have a lot of books but at the
end of the day if those things are
adding value there's nothing wrong with
holding on to those things like with art
supplies I know that a lot of my artist
friends they have things that they may
not use for a year or two some of my
organized friends they've got a specific
space set aside where they keep all of
that stuff and when that space gets full
they will start to remove some things
and replace it with other
different equipment or supplies that
they want to that they want to use in
the future so making rules like that can
certainly help you know I Ryan and I
differ quite a bit on on this topic I
think personally think that collecting
is dangerous and if you just pull up a
dictionary or thesaurus you'll find that
synonym for collecting is hoarding and
so I think collections are inherently
dangerous as well that they aren't
necessarily evil or but but they can get
in the way because we we can justify
them very easily and so what I say is if
you have a collection that truly adds
value to your life that brings you so
much joy that or you're able to use it
quite frequently then great hold on to
it but don't justify it by saying well
it completes my collection while your
collection doesn't actually complete you
and so if you have all of these art
supplies and materials or whatever may
be temporary temporarily remove them
from your life do around it with his
packing party and box up all these
supplies and go get the ones you
actually use over the course of well
like what ryan did with 21 days or maybe
it's 30 days for you or maybe it's 90
days for you we have something called
the 9090 rule have I used this in the
last 90 days and am I going to use it in
the next 90 days and if so great I'm
going to hold on to it and I do that for
clothes a lot of the time or a bunch of
other seasonal items because it covers
all seasons and the truth is it by
limiting yourself often especially with
with art limiting yourself enhances the
creative process and so maybe try that
out so so box some stuff up so you don't
actually have to get rid of it or donate
it right away but you can find a way to
let go of it temporarily and unpack the
things you truly need and then let go of
the whatever else remains yeah I mean
really it just comes down to forming a
plan and really being clear on what you
want to get out of that plan so when it
comes to the art supplies what is your
result what do you want do you want
feel better because you have less art
supplies and it's less cluttered then
great use that and form a plan around it
and stick to it and and whittle that
down yeah and don't assume you have to
get rid of something in order to be more
of a minimalist right if you find value
in it great yeah I've totally met
minimalist with book collections no
matter what Josh thinks no I'm kidding
all right third third question here from
Frank Martin Frank mark Frank Martin
asks what was the most difficult thing
for each of you to get rid of you know
people will ask that question in their
other like was that the big screen TV or
was it your Lexus or was it your
whatever and the truth is the most
difficult thing for me to get rid of
wasn't a physical thing
it was my identity the first question we
tend to ask other people is what do you
do and we get so tied up in the answer
to that question the title that's on our
business card that we think that's who
we are as a person that becomes our
identity and and really for me I had to
change that over time and the way I
change the answer to that question was I
stopped answering with my job title
because I had an impressive job title
I'm the director of operations for 150
retail stores but ultimately I realized
that I could answer that question with
what I was passionate about and so then
I would say you know I'm passionate
about writing what are you passionate
about and it would totally change the
direction of that conversation from us
talking about work to us talking about
something we truly cared about yeah for
me it was my cat it was really hard to
find my cat a good home and get rid of
him
no in all seriousness and that was a
very difficult thing it was one of these
decisions I had to make because I was
enjoying his company when I was home but
that was the problem was I wasn't home
often we were going on tours and I had
to leave him with my mom for a couple
weeks and then he'd come back and be all
angry and I could just see his health
deteriorating so I knew I had to to do
something
that was that was really difficult and
that's an answer I've never given before
so a question from Facebook
sissie asks how does someone expand
their vocabulary Josh you know I I teach
a writing class called how to write
better and if anyone is interested in
that I'm not trying to promote that here
but it's at how to write better org but
the one thing that I talk about is we
want to expand our vocabulary not to
impress others but for the sake of
precision if we are armed with a larger
arsenal of words then we can find the
right word for the right situation and
if you really want to expand your
vocabulary well you know one of the best
ways to do that is to learn one new word
every day and there are a bunch of
places you can go to to do that I mean
you can get the word of the day from
your computer or from dictionary calm
for me the way I like to do it is I tend
to read a lot in any fun time I find a
new word that I don't know or that I do
know but I don't regularly incorporate
into my vocabulary well then I find a
way to use it that were 21 times in one
day now you have to wedge that into
conversations they use it 21 times if
it's a word you've never used before but
takes 21 times to build a habit and what
happens is the good words tend to stick
and the ones that just don't work out
for me they fall by the wayside so I
think that's a great way to expand your
vocabulary and if you want a bunch of
writing tips my how to write better
class has a free Facebook page and a
free Twitter page and I tend to tweet
free daily tips also my adjunct
professor Sean the Halleck does a bunch
of really cool stuff with both of both
of those accounts so you can just go to
how to write better org and find
Facebook and Twitter to get a bunch of
writing tips on Instagram Jessica asks
how do you explain to someone that you
don't want thing
for gifts but just their company or food
to eat or useful things yeah that's
definitely not an easy situation to to
approach but there is a solution I what
I've done is I have approached friends
or family members and have just had the
conversation it will start out something
like you know this year I'm really
trying to keep things simple and I want
to make the most out of my holidays so
my plans for this holidays is to if you
really need something let me know but my
plan is to maybe take you to a movie or
let's go out to dinner let's have an
experience together or I bought Mariah
some concert tickets for Christmas so I
so having those conversations are not
easy but going to your loved ones and
and having that approach certainly again
if they do love you if they do want you
to be happy
they war they will support you with
Mariah's mom she she asked me what do I
get you as minimalist what should I get
you as a gift and that's exactly what I
told her I said you know if you can just
cook an amazing meal make some lamb
meatballs that would be awesome and
that's exactly what she did she made
some lamb meatballs and it was really
really good and we all enjoyed it and
she made me some snacks and stuff that
uh she gave me for Christmas but
ultimately I think it comes down to
expectations you know and I wouldn't set
that expectation on Thanksgiving for
Christmas set it way in advance
eight months ten months in advance that
hey I know Christmas is way down the
line but I want you to know right now
that I truly don't need anything and
that the best present is presents and if
you're willing to spend the holiday with
me or if you're willing to gift an
experience or some sort of consumable
I'd love that but I really want to be
able to spend my time with you and
that's what's most precious I don't need
another necktie another pair of
cufflinks I don't need some widget that
isn't going to add any additional
purpose to my life what I need from you
is you yeah and I would say anyone who
reacts negatively to either of those
approaches then I would be questioning
whether or not it's someone
that I should hang out with all the time
meaning meaning that people still may
get you gifts and people do still get me
gifts my grandma sent me this like big
ice scraper and I just kind of smile and
nodded and sent her a thank you
and and then I I donated it god I hope
she's not listening right now no she
would totally she would totally
appreciate that um because you've done a
good job with with setting expectation
exactly on Instagram at the minimalists
Mandy asks when you're trying to reduce
the stuff that you have do you find it
better to just donate it or sell it kind
of a time versus money question yeah I
would agree this is definitely a time
versus money question I find it yes I
find it best to donate it or sell yes
you know really I think it's up to you
when I was I had a lot of debt back in
my corporate days even though I made
great money I had six figures worth of
debt so eBay and Craigslist became
really great friends of mine because I
used both of those tools those resources
to sell especially large items I wanted
to get rid of and that would allow me to
get money that I otherwise couldn't that
I could use to pay down many of my
credit cards and just different debts
that I had but if you don't have a ton
of debt and you're looking to get rid of
the stuff pretty quickly
you know what donating it somewhere to
someone who can use it is great
ultimately it's about finding the stuff
a new home just because you don't get
valuing the stuff doesn't mean that
someone else won't get value and so
let's find it a new home where someone
else can enjoy it yeah when I was
donating stuff after my packing party it
felt really good to give just like a
couple little gadgets like a nice nice
little handheld video camera that I had
there was some like extra cell phones
that that I had donated but it felt
really good to think about someone
coming across these awesome finds in a
in a donation warehouse somewhere it
just felt really I know that when I was
growing up and I would find
these great little deals shopping at
those places it made me really excited
so makes me happy thinking that there's
some kid who's coming across some you
know cell phone that's eight years old
but he's really really happy that he's
got access to a cell phone for whatever
well totally you uh
Rebecca's daughter my partner her
daughters too and she has a little fake
cell phone and absolutely loves the
thing pretend she's calling me on it all
the time and she calls me to ask to talk
to herself which is interesting but
tried to explain that to a two-year-old
but yeah you know sometimes our old toys
so to speak can be actual toys for for
someone else and it's interesting I was
at a Christmas recently at Becca's
family selves and you know there are a
lot of toys there from generations past
you don't have to hold on to those
things those what I've learned is you
can go on eBay and buy a whole box of
toys for twenty dollars and then when
your kid grows up or grows out of those
toys you can put it right back on eBay
for 20 bucks and treat that as your your
storage cabinet you don't have to hold
on to them in in perpetuity yeah mmm
we're still Instagram at the minimalists
Katie asks how do you guys define value
what does value mean to you as a
minimalist every possession I own serves
a purpose or brings me joy and that's
what I mean by adding value to my life
does a serve a purpose can I use it for
something
does it have function or does it just
really bring me joy and that can be
music that can be artwork and no matter
what it is I have to be honest with
myself the things that add value to my
life today may not add value tomorrow so
you never get there you don't own your
1000 items or your 100 items and get
your official minimalism certificate no
you keep asking that question does this
add value to my life and I'm 34 years
old right now and the things that add
value to my life now will be
not add value when I'm 54 years old and
so I have to keep asking that question
let's move on to periscope which is also
at the minimalists at JD rkx asks the
five values in your book minimalism live
a meaningful life are health
relationships passion growth and
contribution if there was a sixth value
what would it be you know I've been
having a ton of fun on periscope this
past month throughout December of 2015
and January 2016 we're doing live events
on periscope Tuesdays with the
minimalists Tuesdays with the minimalist
and so you can join us at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern for Tuesdays with minimalist
where we do lightning round questions
live on camera you know I think we
probably have both have different
answers for this but we just published
the the second edition of minimalism
live a meaningful life and really just
expanded on the five values in that book
I think those are those are higher order
values so if I were to look at what's a
more baseline value I think ultimately
it's something like security and that
can mean a bunch of different things
security can mean safety
it could mean do I have shelter do I
have clothing do I have food and then do
I have things like liberty and happiness
and freedom and so if I were to add a
sixth value it would be it could be any
of those but I would really if I were to
narrow down I would say freedom and in
particular a a particular kind of
freedom financial freedom and I don't
mean making a bunch of money so that
you're happy I don't think that's the
key to happiness but not being bogged
down by the constant stress that money
puts on us the constant worry it's one
of the things that we fight about with
our loved ones with our business
partners etc but when we take the stress
out of money makes life a whole heck of
a lot easier so we wrote an essay I'd
love for you all to read it's called
financial freedom
it's one of the most beneficial things
that I know we've written because we've
had thousands and thousands of people
who have commented that they have gotten
a ton of value from it so that's at the
minimalists comm slash freedom and what
ryan i talk about is how we got out of
debt
how we started planning for the future
and how we stopped worrying about money
even though when we walked away from the
corporate world we made appreciably less
money but we were able to regain control
of our finances yeah it's funny when
people hear the term financial freedom
they assume well that must mean you know
having a million dollars in the bank or
having a hundred thousand dollars saved
up for what whatever it is and I would
say if you're debt-free that you were
80% of the way there to financial
freedom now getting debt-free that is
certainly a long road it was a long road
for Josh and I and and certainly people
are all over the spectrum with how much
debt they have but but yet definitely
check out that essay if you're if you're
looking to get financial freedom it's it
is it's a great plan that we both follow
what about your value if you were to add
one value to the five values Ryan and my
value oh I would have to say is probably
creation because I just I feel so much
better when I create something unique
and something that I really really love
whether it be a country song just just
so you could put some context of that
with you yours and in Mariah's sort of
backstory on your entry song yeah so
that's it's a little side hobby that me
and my girlfriend have we are writing a
country album we've got a three or four
songs right now and you don't listen you
don't listen the country I do that
listen it all started on a on a bet that
I could write a country song within 20
minutes and I did and when I was done I
was like wow I really like this song so
as a as a as a joke kind of we started
writing an
them together but but every time we come
up with a new song and I'm playing I'm
like wow like if I could get a band by
and this sounds really good but but any
time I have those moments whether it's
writing whether it's going snowboarding
in getting a new trick down or whatever
it may be creating something new it
really really fuels my fire I think
creation can go along with that that
cultivating passion aspect yeah but
ultimately I have found myself before
where I've been cultivating passions but
not creating for a while and I've
noticed that when I start to create
stuff I feel better about myself it's a
great antidote to consumption as well
yeah the more we consume the less we
create but of course the opposite is
also true
the more we create the more fulfilled
more fulfilled we feel and therefore
don't feel the need to fill that void
with mindless consumption let's move on
to the so we have a peel box if you want
to write us a postcard
we prefer those to email in fact we
don't really do the whole email QA thing
very often just because it's we can get
bogged down with that kind of stuff but
so that's what we get enough emails
already yeah and I don't find email very
meaningful and and so I try to limit
that but we love getting very
intentional postcards so you can go to
the minimalists dot-com slash contact
and find all of our mailing information
there Evan from Bartlett Illinois writes
I'm a senior in high school and I have a
dilemma I love what you say about not
having a job or a career oh wait a
minute
and how people should do what they're
passionate about wait a second okay we
can clarify those in a minute Evan
that's maybe a overly simplistic view of
how we look at the world we don't think
there's anything inherently wrong with
having a job I'll tell you I think a
career can actually be pretty dangerous
and here's why I say that is often our
careers are
six out of ten we get comfortable with
our career but many of us don't find our
career meaningful we and so we don't
experience enough discontent to make a
change but we don't experience enough
pleasure to feel fulfilled to feel happy
to feel that sense of purpose or mastery
or autonomy that we all need when we are
creating and so having jobs okay I think
we all need to pay the bills but I would
prefer to have a mission and so you said
here how people should do what they're
passionate about I don't think you
should do what you're passionate about I
think you should find a way to cultivate
a passion and so we'll continue with
your question here the problem having is
I'm passionate about multiple things and
I don't know which one I should follow
especially since it will ultimately
affect my college pursuits at first I
try to do it all I tried to be Superman
but now I realize that's not realistic
one of my passions is violin and I need
to practice ideally about five to six
hours every single day I'm also
extremely passionate about music
composition and my dream is to be a
composer that would make my day but
other than music I'm incredibly
passionate about theater literature and
writing all pretty heavy stuff the
current situation is that in order to
achieve the proficiency required in
violin I will need to give up pretty
much everything else I'm stretched too
thin even though I love everything I'm
doing it's just too much I'm really
struggling to find time for my family
and my friends I don't have a social
life whatsoever well here's the thing
you're right you are you are stretched
too thin and what you're saying here the
current situation is that in order to
achieve the proficiency required in
violin I have to sacrifice everything
else that's true but I just wants a
violin I would say you have to pick a
category and it's one of the common
misconceptions we make especially before
we're age 30 and many people who are
older than 30 as well but in high school
you're in a great great spot oven
because let's
you're 15 years old and you've got like
65 years ahead of you right yeah and you
can pick a passion and really cultivate
it over the next 10 years right and then
when you're 25 you can pick a different
passion and cultivate that passion over
the next 10 years to be young again and
when you're 35 you can pick a third
passion and cultivate that for the next
10 years and you over the course of
several decades you'll have many
passions that you've pursued and I would
actually encourage you to get obsessed
with some of these things I think I
think that's what passion is it's one
half obsession it's one half love and
you need to be able to balance that out
and you can't balance that out when
you're spread too thin here's the key
pick one thing it sounds to me like it's
violent you know and really focus on
being passionate about that you have to
Drudge through the drudgery
you're not going to it's not all going
to be ponies and rainbows all the time
but that's when the real payoff comes
because what I used to do throughout my
twenties is I would think I was
passionate about one thing I'm really
passionate about the short story idea in
that write write write write write write
write write
and then I'll wait this has gotten hard
the writing is hard why do I want to do
something that's hard like to do
something easy like get on Facebook or
or watch TV or pacify myself with my
phone but there's no real payoff in that
the real payoff is from drudging through
the drudgery putting in the work until
you get to the other side of that
drudgery that's when you're going to
experience the payoff so pick one thing
and I'd say focus on it Evan you want to
move on to the reader comments
absolutely so if you have a question for
us you can always call in to our phone
number or you can of course use the
hashtag ask the minimalist and we have a
bunch of comments from our previous
episode and just comments in general so
if you want to comment on this episode
all you have to do is give us a call at
four zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine
and we will air our favorites and also
since monograph books to some of our
favorite comments now I know there are
some people out there who want to call
in and ask us a question but they're
really scared about having their voice
on air what I will say is we have an
excellent editor so if you call and you
ramble like I do during these podcasts
Sean will edit it and make it sound
beautiful so you can rest assure that we
will not put you on air and make you
sound incoherent we will make it
coherent yeah absolutely and and if you
do want to write a comment the best
place to do that is on iTunes we read
every single review there so if you find
value that's a great place to do it
we also post this on youtube so
Alexandria writes I love your podcast
however I wish you put it on iTunes so I
don't have to keep my screen on it's a
good idea and good thing we are doing it
and so you can find the podcast on
iTunes you can also find it on
soundcloud and pretty soon you'll find
it on stitcher and your stitches popular
with the young kids these days I don't
even know what that means
all right so soundcloud.com slash the
minimalists marbles and jam writes i
declutter regularly but this podcast is
a good reminder that i keep looking at
the same splashguard thing and my
cupboard over and over and thinking i
should donate it but i never do no more
i just put it in my donation box
congratulations marbles and jam for
taking action absolutely that's awesome
and on iTunes Oh
Otero writes best 7 second intro ever
well thank you I couldn't agree more we
think advertisements suck and our p.o
box postcard this week Tara of Columbus
Ohio Oh Ohio writes I want to share with
you how your book everything that
remains influenced me to begin the
process of making a lifestyle change two
and a half years ago I was looking for
real store
race to relate to and to develop my own
roadmap for change I took the first
steps out of the corporate grind in 2014
I was single making good money but I was
paralyzed by fear yeah this is a pretty
long letter what I really liked about
this letter she goes through kind of the
steps she had taken and then she jumps
to where she's at now she writes I am 2
years out of corporate America now and
self-employed with encouraging success
however my income was reduced by nearly
65 percent I am coming to the
realization I will likely have to move
to a cheaper rental I have had to turn
down travel offers and I often can't
afford to dine with my good friends but
now I set my own schedule I accomplish
things for people by the end of the day
I actually like most of the people I
work with and I don't schedule anything
before 10:00 a.m. i guard my mornings I
work hours that are productive and
convenient my daily life now reflects my
values so much better than one with a
comfortable income I am full of
gratitude for being non
institutionalized I think I figured out
a better way to live and my life had to
get smaller to do it and I just really
really loved that last line my life had
to get smaller to do it and at the end
of the day that is what it takes
sometimes I I was a little confused when
I was reading her letter I didn't know
if it was like a positive or negative
thing that she started talking about how
she had to miss out on travel how she
had to reduce her salary how she had to
turn down going out to eat with friends
but ultimately what she is writing about
is how those decisions helped her really
come out of this this crazy situation
that she was in so thanks for writing
that we really appreciate you Tara and
keep up the great work finally to round
out this segment let's go ahead and
listen to a comment voicemail from
Vanessa hey guys Nessa from Ohio and I
just wanted to call and say thank you
because back in 2000
in 2012 my husband and I moved from a
thousand square foot house for the two
of us to a 500 square foot studio
because of the market downturn and not
selling our house as we thought we would
we had to downsize and I was in tears
with the film's my mom and we found that
we were expecting at the same time which
was something we were hoping for but
also not hoping for in a 500 square foot
studio apartment and when she sent me
your link to your blog and then as a
joke maybe I should read up and because
I was being forced into that lifestyle
but that month of transition in our
lives was probably the best thing that
could have ever happened to us Thank You
Vanessa
Thank You Vanessa so ultimately I mean
what it sounds like is Vanessa there you
know was kind of going through a similar
thing as Tara from Ohio also from Ohio
she and her husband had to downsize they
were forced into minimalism they were
stressed out but minimalism allows us to
remove some of that stress we're no
longer so focused on the outside world
and that allows us to focus a lot more
on what's going on inside us yeah
ultimately we want to understand what's
going on inside us so we can add as much
value to other people it's funny because
a couple times at our meetups people who
they've brought up the thing of
minimalism selfish you're always talking
about doing things for yourself and
ultimately that's where it starts if you
want to produce awesome value in the
world or do some amazing things
ultimately you do have to be taken care
of first
in order to help others but it's not
just about gratifying our own needs we
think the meaning of life is growth and
giving and so being able to contribute
to the world around you is one of the
most important one of the most
fulfilling and one of the most
growth inducing experiences we can have
so the more we give the more we grow and
the more we grow the more we have to
give it's a really beautiful cycle amen
let's move on to our vatted value
segment this is the minimalist
recommendations for this week I every
year I publish a list toward the
beginning of each year where I look at
my favorite albums from the previous
year
and so I won't list off all 15 from 2015
but I will mention a few of them here
Matt carnies album just kids was amazing
Sufjan Stevens was that albums called
Karen Lowell
I haven't been a huge Sufjan Stevens fan
in the past but man that I really really
love this album I love Drake's new album
- I was number one on my list actually
if you're reading this it's too late and
a bunch of other recommendations you can
find all of those at the minimalists
dot-com slash sound as well as my
previous year's recommendations this is
sort of backed by popular demand we've
had so many people who tweet and ask are
you going to publish a list in fact this
year was my former spouse two days
before she gave birth to her twins early
January she tweeted me and said have you
created your top ten list or top 15 it's
an awesome list dude every year like I
look forward to it man it's such awesome
reviews I appreciate that and so I've
got 15 of them there and then some
honorable mentions on the list and I'm
currently listening to a group called a
quill oh they have an awesome EP and
hopefully one day they'll put a a album
out and it'll make it onto one of these
lists so the minimalist calm slash sound
check it out and let me know you can
comment there as well on on my Google+
post which is where the minimalist calm
slash sound will take you I'd love to
hear some of your favorite picks of 2015
yeah for me this week I've got to give
it give a shout-out to my friend Robin
Devine over at she makes hats calm who
knitted me
this delightful wool hat that I'm
wearing right now let's be honest she
has knitted you at least seven different
hats and it's not because he's hoarding
hats it's because he loses somehow Milly
why you gotta call me out like that okay
so she made me this hat in several
others that I've lost on ski trails and
concerts and whatever else I've actually
had this one for about a year and a half
she did text me I swear like around
Thanksgiving right before you know the
snow started picking up here she's like
do you need another hat yet so yeah she
does know me but that's just it she
makes awesome hats everything that she
sells it goes towards a lot of it goes
towards charity she's doing this amazing
thing she's trying this is how we
actually met her and at asymmetrical
press we are publishing house we
actually published one of her books
called she makes hats she's doing this
awesome thing she's trying to knit
10,000 hats for the world around her now
some of those go to homeless shelters
and in different places but some just go
to people were doing cool stuff if she
wants to say thank you for doing what
you do and I tell she met us yeah she
makes great hats if your noggin his cold
checkout she makes hats calm awesome
I've got a few final updates before we
close it out later this month in January
the 23rd through the 25th Ryan and I are
finally fulfilling our dream of becoming
baristas at least for three days you can
see us three caffeinated days with the
minimalists if you go to the minimalists
comm slash bandit you can find all of
the information our friends joshua
weaver and sarah weaver also married
couple in st. Petersburg Florida are
opening a coffee shop there and it's one
of our favorite cities in the world
we're excited to finally go back this is
the perfect time in January and we're
going to make some drinks for you we're
also doing a charity screening of our
documentary minimalism and unfortunately
for you that documentary is sold out but
don't worry very very soon we're going
to have all kinds of really cool
information for you on how you can bring
our documentary minimalism to your city
it will be in theaters on May 24th
20:16 and you can help us bring our
documentary to your city or your suburb
very soon stay tuned for details on that
you can find more about that film and a
bunch of excerpts at minimalism film
comm and if you're looking to connect
with some like-minded people in your
area you can check out our free local
meetup groups at minimalist org we left
behind a hundred free local meetup
groups in eight different countries last
time we went on a big tour and a lot of
those groups are flourishing and if you
don't have a group near you don't worry
that's okay we have an online city so
you can meet with folks online as well
just go to minimalist org to find your
city if you found value in this podcast
we really hope you do then please
comment on iTunes let us know what you
liked what you didn't like you can also
subscribe to the minimalists via email
and if you want to support this podcast
it's 100% advertisement free because of
people like you you can just donate a
buck over at the minimalists com slash
donate you can find links to everything
we mentioned today in our show notes the
minimalists comm slash podcast and as
always we hope you found value in our
podcast and if you leave here with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works alright folks
that's it for today's episode
this podcast was produced by Sean
Harding our theme music was written and
performed by Peter Dorn for more Peters
music visit minimalists comm slash Peter
if you have a question or a comment for
the minimalists give us a call at four
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or post your question on social
media using the hashtag ask the
minimalists see you next time every
little thing you think that's me every
little thing you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it every little thing that you
got a hang
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach forward
you got a grand oh I bet that you'll be
fine without me
so J or T